[Musique]
le Sky écho sur le Big tour le festival
des entrepreneurs Patrice se poursuit et
on se poursuit avec le
lneck qui est directeur général adjoint
du ln bonjour bonjour alors
tout à fait donc nous sommes présents
sur le site de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
donc notre laboratoire à Trappes et puis
aussi notre siège est à Paris dont on
est très content d'être ici parce qu'on
a aussi un acteur local de Saint-Quentin
et un acteur de l'innovation et des
recherches complètement donc on fait
alors notre on a beaucoup travaillé sur
notre médecine dont on va essayer de
trouver de résumer tout ce que l'on fait
en une phrase c'est un peu notre
problème on fait tellement de choses
dans le domaine des technologies je peux
arriver à se résumer c'est pas facile
donc on va trouver ça être le
laboratoire de référence des
technologies de demain alors bien sûr
les médecines sont toujours un petit peu
prétentieux mais derrière il y a une
réalité parce que quelque part quand on
est confronté à toutes ces innovations
qui viennent perturber un petit peu
notre notre quotidien nous progresser
révolutionner nos façons de travailler
de produire il y a toujours un petit peu
un questionnement existentiel c'est
est-ce que tout ça c'est vraiment un
facteur de progrès ou est-ce que
derrière il y a pas un petit peu des
risques qui se cachent donc nous on a
bien on a bien avoir cette expression de
d'innovation raisonnée et conseiller un
petit peu que l'innovation c'est un
petit peu comme un enfant qui grandit il
faut la prendre par la main et avec
notre travail on apprend par la main et
on arrive à faire quelque chose qui soit
une innovation qui soit perçue
complètement comme comme un progrès et
ça on peut le voir effectivement au
travers de différentes technologies
comme les nanomatériaux l'intelligence
artificielle ou les encore les
technologies quantiques on peut en
parler juste un mot laboratoire national
c'est une entité publique ou privée
alors ça aussi c'est une spécificité
donc on est un peu un petit peu à la
croisée des deux mondes on est
effectivement un établissement public
mais industriel et commercial donc pour
le faire court nos revenus sont 20% de
subventions mais qui sont bien calés sur
des sujets de recherche fondamentale
dans le domaine de la métrologie je pour
vous parler du kilogramme quantique du
kilo de RAM quantique et puis aussi on a
80% de nos ressources c'est du chiffre
d'affaires des clients industriels qui
viennent nous consulter parfois qui nous
mettent en concurrence d'ailleurs avec
d'autres et justement on vient les aider
pour les aider à stabiliser leurs
produits aller alors vous vous venez
clairement faire les recherches pour les
entreprises vous êtes une partie R&D
pour certaines entreprises ou vous venez
tester justement des solutions qui sont
proposées par les entreprises donc nous
on a on a trois métiers on a le métier
de la de la certification
des essais et de la métrologie donc
quand on a des technologies qui sont
complexes justement on a envie d'avoir
une réponse simple est-ce que ça marche
ou assez est-ce que ça marche pas donc
ça c'est un petit peu la certification
qui va dire un Go ou un logo quand vous
certifié quelque chose il faut pouvoir
avoir derrière des des moyens des moyens
d'essai donc on arrive sur notre métier
notre métier d'essai et puis quand vous
faites des essais c'est bien mais quand
on mesure des choses avec des
technologies nouvelles derrière il faut
mettre en œuvre toute une nouvelle
métrologie je parlais de l'intelligence
artificielle ça veut dire qu'à un moment
il faut arriver à évaluer l'intelligence
artificielle alors vous allez pas faire
ça avec votre balance votre maître ça va
pas marcher donc justement nous c'est
notre métier et on est en train de
mettre en place des
déférés dans le domaine de l'IA avec
aussi des moyens d'essai donc par
exemple on a été attributaire d'un
financement dans le cadre de France
relance pour faire donc à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le 1er
laboratoire en Europe d'évaluation de
l'intelligence artificielle actuellement
il y en a trois dans le monde il y en a
un à Tokyo ou n2i un autre à Washington
oniste de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique
et puis en Europe ça sera à
Saint-Quentin donc c'est un laboratoire
qui j'insiste sur cet aspects là qui
sera
tiers de confiance on est nous on n'est
pas lié à un industriel voilà donc on
est capable d'avoir ces moyens d'essai
qui sont qui sont qui sont indépendants
on disait souvent justement que la
France était propre était plutôt en
retard en matière d'intelligence
artificielle est-ce que c'est toujours
vrai ou est-ce que on est en train de
reconquérir ce terrain ah bah il y a
certainement beaucoup de choses qui se
font en Europe et le fait justement de
pousser ses moyens d'évaler sur des
certifications c'est une façon de
d'imposer un petit peu les standards les
standards européens parce que derrière
toutes ces technologies innovantes ce
qu'il faut voir c'est qu'il y a la
question de la de la compétition
industrielle si on prend le le sujet du
quantique par exemple on a aussi présent
sur les technologies quantiques qui ont
pu avoir là encore un financement dans
le cadre de France de 2030 avec la
stratégie nationale quantique quand on
veut faire quand on veut être leader
sur une industrie quelconque c'est
toujours mieux si quelque part les
normes qui s'appliquent vous avez
participé à la définition de ces normes
donc ça on le comprend mais derrière les
normes les normes s'appuient aussi sur
des référentiels donc en fait si on veut
vraiment gagner le
gagner la bataille
plus près il faut justement mettre les
moyens le paquet sur ces référentiels
parce que derrière vous allez avoir les
normes et puis ensuite vous allez avoir
les standards de production donc
actuellement sur les technologies
quantiques on est justement en train
d'essayer de d'imposer les standards qui
vont bien et on espère que ce soit
plutôt des standards qui soient
européens avec une participation
française plutôt que des standards qui
soient américains ou chinois
actuellement les les pays qui
investissent beaucoup sur toutes ces
questions de métrologie c'est la Chine
la Corée du Sud et on comprend pourquoi
et enfin pourquoi un des travailleurs
que vous faites aussi c'est sur les
Nanomat matériaux et là on va plus
parler d'environnement finalement vous
participez à la transition
environnementale alors pas seulement
environnement sur les réseaux matériaux
parce que les nanomatériaux
effectivement on a pu entendre un petit
peu des inquiétudes je parlais
d'innovation raisonnée de avoir
confiance dans l'innovation donc les
nanomatériaux c'est vrai qu'on peut en
avoir dans des produits que l'on
consomme comme les pâtes dentifrice ce
qui rend blanc la pâte dentifrice et de
l'autre site de titane qu'on peut
retrouver dans les pattes dentifrice
mais vous avez aussi des nanomatériaux
qui peuvent être dans l'industrie
automobile pour les pneus pour les
carrosseries et puis aussi
des applications comme par exemple dans
le domaine de la santé actuellement on
travaille beaucoup avec une Nanobiotix
qui produit donc des des médicaments qui
sont portés par des matériaux pour aller
soigner la cellule cancéreuse donc au
plus près donc là on va vraiment tomber
dans une utilisation complètement
positive de l'innovation mais derrière
après se pose justement la question de
la caractérisation est sous le
nanomatériaux il va vraiment fonctionner
est-ce que c'est reproductible et vous
voyez on revient encore à ces questions
de métrologie c'est toujours difficile
de juger le futur c'est ça la difficulté
d'autre complètement et vous disiez tout
à l'heure c'est très intéressant qui est
à la fois le besoin d'innovation des
entreprises et puis le besoin de
sécurité de la société est-ce que
au sein de du laboratoire il y a des
chercheurs probablement est-ce qu'il y a
aussi des une sorte de comité d'éthique
oui tout à fait on s'est doté d'un
comité d'éthique pour vérifier ce que
parfois sur certains qui apprécie on ne
soit il est pas des conflits d'intérêts
parce que c'est vrai que je tourne on a
une activité comme je le disais qui est
à la fois publique mais aussi commercial
que l'on touche à des métiers qui
peuvent être à la fois du référentiel
mais aussi des essais qui sont en
compétition avec avec d'autres il faut
faire attention à savoir où on habite et
effectivement on a un comité d'éthique
qui peut nous aider parfois à bien voir
ce que tu l'ont fait notamment dans le
domaine du médical merci beaucoup
parce que ce que vous êtes dans ce monde
de demain vous êtes plutôt quelqu'un
d'optimiste
on travaille sur les technologies de
demain il faut forcément croire bien sûr
et on va se tenir au courant sur le Sky
Eco de l'activité du LNE dans les
prochains mois merci beaucoup c'est
beaucoup merci je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur général adjoint du ln attrape
merci
[Musique]